max's car can drive for itself
some of the time it's got an autopilot
system
which can take over as long as he keeps
his eye on the road
and his hands on the wheel i think i'm
quite aware of being there as the driver
it's my responsibility if something
happens
i've got my family in the car right like
the buck stops with me
but i think the um the slight delegation
having something else do the
moment-to-moment stuff does free you up
a bit to feel a bit more like a
passenger
we could be seeing more of this kind of
technology according to new proposals
from the government
which is investigating whether to make
it legal to use more advanced
automated systems on motorways
hands-free
so i got a bit confused there doesn't
like roundabouts
beeped and prompted me to take over
because
there were two lanes and a roundabout
and it didn't know what to do
it'll be in the slow lane only and
they'll be checked to see if drivers are
paying attention
but still is this a step towards
driverless cars
people have been saying that driverless
cars are right around the corner for
about 10 years
but they never arrive and the reason is
that to go from a car like this
to one like this which helps you
automatically is technologically
speaking
a relatively small step to go to a
driverless car is a huge step
and that's why they don't and might
never exist
most self-driving vehicles aren't out on
roads
like these test cars but are instead in
confined areas like industrial sites or
residential estates
the company behind their software says
this latest development
is still an important moment it's
limited in its functionality but if you
take a helicopter view
it's still a vehicle deciding on its
steering and its speed
without you steering or controlling the
speed and it has to perceive its
environments got to know where it is
it's got to know what other vehicles are
these are the building blocks of
autonomy
right hover no doubt so where am i
what's around me what should i do
those are the three pillars of autonomy
and they are present in this system
the department for transport said it
would start a formal consultation on the
proposals
at the end of the year things are moving
forward
although not at motorway speed
roland mantha sky news